romrod mit globetrotter darm spezialist
für mosley dritte rad globetrotter
punktzahl
[Musik]
morgen morgen kann ich ein fahrrad
mieten für einen tag
ja ich bin in burma im gebiet der schon
einer minderheit hier im städtchen zippo
wohnte er letzter prinz den sie
verehrten bis heute gilt als verschollen
ich mache mich auf den weg zum palast
[Musik]
unsere reise entlang der firma roth
begangen in der südchinesischen stadt
kunming sie führte über dali bis zur
grenze trulli wieder erreichen burma das
heutige myanmar und sind nun in cebu
city wird beschaulich aber in der
umgebung im state wird illegal moon für
den drogenhandel angebaut
die regierungs truppen nutzen den
drogenhandel als vorwand um sich immer
wieder scharmützel mit den schauen zu
liefern
vor dem ehemaligen palast des prinzen
treffe ich meinen übersetzerin fußball
ausgeschlossen gibt es jeden eine
möglichkeit trotzdem reinzukommen
ich frage mal weißt du wenn die
besitzerin zurück
ich weiß nicht wie man da vielleicht ich
bin unter gärten die enkelin auch nicht
okay es ist niemand da
das ist bloß der gärtner hat keinen
schlüssel es anfang der 60er jahre lebte
der schon für stars eng mit seiner
familie in dieser weder seine frau und
er den usa kennen eine österreicherin
der fürst reformierter das portalsystem
und boten bauern faire bedingungen dem
autoritären militärischen das 1962 an
die macht kam ging das zu weit
er wurde verschleppt seitdem ist er
verschollen
seine frau flüchtete später mit den
töchtern in die usa und lebt bis heute
dort
mehr über diese geschichte könne mir die
betreiberin vermisse stop-kurs garden
erzählen
mit popcorn eigentlich emin t schön
dieser garten willkommen ist ob als
garten
seit drei jahren betreibt sie dieses
restaurant bitte diesen drink mit
pfefferminz und ja ja ja oder wahrhaben
wie sie wollen wie bekannt danke betrieb
früher eine popcorn fabrik zusammen mit
ihrem mann aber die konkurrenz aus china
wurde zu groß sie musste den betrieb
aufgeben
aus der schamfrist sackgassen regierte
war komitee noch ein kind aber sie
verehrt ihn bis heute
seine liebe zum volk ist legende mit
einem büchlein seiner geschichte bewahrt
sie ihr andenken an ihn ist ein
hochzeitsfoto des prinzen und der
prinzessin
das traditionelle foto das ist seine
ältere tochter und dass die jüngere ja
sie hatten zwei zwei töchter manchmal
spielten sie mit uns die kleine ja wir
waren im selben alter
sie sagten unter dem prinzen seines
glückliche zeiten gewesen haben es war
mir kinder meisten spielten
niemand machte sich damals sorgen um das
fest es gab genug für alle
wirtschaftlich ging es mit unsere eltern
hatten keine sorgen
heutzutage ist das anders
wir sind alle gezwungen hart zu arbeiten
auch die kinder
es gibt viel streit damals konnten wir
zur schule gehen und spielen
es war eine gute zeit sie sagten dass
der prinz die bauern gut behandelte
inwiefern der prinz saß viel land
er erlaubte den bauern dieses zu nutzen
dafür gaben sie ihm einen teil der ernte
von zehn säcke reis haben sie drei ab
dafür mussten sie nichts investieren
das schwein volk liebte seinen prinz
waagerecht in burma leben heute etwa
fünf millionen schon knapp ein zehntel
der bevölkerung geschaffen waren bis
1948 autonom die britischen
kolonialherren tolerierten ihr
fördersystem im gegenzug bauten sie die
rohstoffe des landes ab als das militär
die macht übernahm verloren die
scharniere unabhängigkeit
seitdem kämpfen sie für mehr autonomie
der 76-jährige klarmann ist ein neffe
des verstorbenen prinzen vor 50 jahren
kämpfte er für die scham in ihrer armee
heute verschafft er sich gewaltlos gehör
und kämpft als regionalpolitiker für die
rechte der minderheit
unser ziel ist ein systemwechsel wir
wollen bundesländer damit der
gleichberechtigung und selbstbestimmung
für unseren staat jetzt arbeite ich als
politiker
ich bin präsident der sml die der
fahnder schnell league for democracy für
november hat die regierung waren
angekündigt es kann gut sein dass die
usdp partei die mit dem militär jetzt
ist doch wahlmanipulation versucht an
der macht zu bleiben
sie sagen sie werden wahlen machen im
november aber ich glaube nicht dass die
wirklich stattfinden werden
das militär wird die macht übernehmen
aber trotzdem wir müssen weiter kämpfen
wir dürfen nicht locker lassen
die meisten schauen sind kleinbauern und
lebe den kargen verhältnissen burma
gehört zu den ärmsten ländern der welt
trotz riesiger rohstoffvorkommen gold
edelsteine öl und erdgas aber davon
haben sie nichts vor allem der große
nachbar china profitiert die pipeline
kommt schon da drüben und für durch
dieses gebiet bis nach china
sie beginnt bei der christian golf und
den garten durchquert das ganze land und
führt zu den raffinerien in kunden im
südwesten chinas für die pipeline hat
die regierung den bauern land abgekauft
für sie ist dass schnelles geld aber
auch ein hohes risiko
der erlös deckt alles ab auch auffällige
folgeschäden
litauen hat einen teil seines landes
verkauft wie viele andere von der
landwirtschaft kann er nicht mehr leben
jetzt betreibt er eine kleine
destillerie er brennt reisschnaps
natürlich will er dass ich davon koste
er wird das ja aus kleber ist der ist
hausgemacht
ich nehme gerne einen schluck wäre es
gut wie stark wie viele 42 42 prozent
der schmeckt viel stärker als wir
tranken vor einiger zeit besuch von
regierungsbeamten hatte ließ er sich
überzeugend sein land zu verkaufen
alle bauern durch deren land die
pipeline führen sollte kriegten besuch
von hohen beamten
sie boten kompensationszahlungen an
waren die bauern einverstanden bekamen
sie das geld schon nach drei wochen die
pipeline durch irland führt erhielten
sie komplett aktions zahlungen wie viel
sie kamen dreimal
ich bekam umgerechnet 4000 dollar für
4000 quadratmeter mit diesem geld musste
er sich eine neue lebensgrundlage
schaffen für seine destillerie nutzt er
den bach neben seinem haus und erzeugt
mit wasserkraft strom nur gerade ein
drittel der bevölkerung hat überhaupt
zugang zu elektrizität
der erlös von gas und öl bleibt in den
händen weniger mächtiger
[Musik]
incity bricht der nächste tag an
wie jeden morgen holen die möglichkeit
das essen ab dass die gläubigen für sie
zubereitet haben
wir reisen mit dem zug weiter
wer wissen will was in einem land vor
sich geht muss auf die bahnhöfe man
übersetzer leo und ich wollen uns
frühzeitig einen platz sichern
so biete zwei tickets nach berlin
wir fahren das kino linse mitten hinein
in die kolonialgeschichte burmas ins
britische empire des letzten
jahrhunderts
die bank hat vor
die tickets für die holzklasse kosten
umgerechnet gerade mal drei franken
die fahrt dauert acht stunden
welche nummer haben wir neun und zehn
das ist hier
[Musik]
in der heutigen folge reisen wir mit dem
zug von zippo nach wien und dann weiter
nach london
[Musik]
ich liebe zugfahrten in asien
nirgendwo sonst kommt man menschen so
schnell leer
alle hier im zug haben sich auf eine
lange reise angestellt schon bald sind
wir in ein gespräch verwickelt diese
frau bestreicht das gesicht ihres enkels
mit der landestypischen tanaka passte
die fein geriebene baumrinde schützt vor
der sonne und pflegt da sie die haut
heller erscheinen lässt gilt sie in
burma aus schönheitsmittel darf ich mal
schauen mit wasser mischen und dann
auftrag für mich nein danke
vielleicht das ist ein guter
sonnenschutz nicht wahr
an der nächsten station steigt die
großmutter mit ihrem enkel schon wieder
aus von ihr habe ich fast alles über die
trucker passte erfahren
manchmal versteht man sich besser wenn
man sich auf gesten und gefühle verlässt
[Musik]
jeder bahnhof ist ein kleiner marktplatz
die passagiere bekommen die mahlzeiten
frisch geliefert wie überall in asien
kam man sich rund um die uhr glücklich
essen essen bringt die menschen zusammen
burma ist ein fruchtbares land 70
prozent der bevölkerung leben von der
landwirtschaft
[Musik]
nach ein paar stunden fahrt hat sich im
zug eine welt mit ihrem eigenen rhythmus
gebildet
[Musik]
allmählich überträgt sich der monotone
takt des tores auf ausreichenden
dann ein höhepunkt der zugfahrt das
urteil viadukt
[Musik]
bei der eröffnung 1900 war diese
eisenbahnbrücke eine weltsensation
die briten gaben sie in auftrag
amerikaner setzten die pläne um das
viadukt ist 800 meter lang
250 meter unter uns ist der fluss wir
können nur noch im schritttempo fahren
die eisenkonstruktion ächzt unter dem
gewicht des zuges
[Musik]
kaum haben wir wieder festen boden unter
den rädern werde ich von dieser familie
zum essen eingeladen
sie gehört zur couch in minderheit ganz
im norden burmas die familie reist nach
manderlay eine station weiter aus wir
sie gehen an die uni abschlussfeier
ihrer tochter ein uniabschluss ist ein
garant für einen guten job
damit die tochter studieren konnte haben
die eltern hart gearbeitet
mein mann hat 27 jahre für die
staatliche eisenbahn gearbeitet
dann ging er in pension ohne eine rente
zu erhalten
ich habe eine kleine orangenplantage das
ermöglicht es uns die kinder studieren
zu lassen
nach dem essen laden mich die eltern
einziehen manderlay zu besuchen
[Musik]
seit in die burmesische geschichte
einzutauchen
der britische autor george orwell war
hier stationiert er kritisierte das
arrogante gebaren seiner landsleute in
der hoch-zeit der britischen
kolonialmacht in einem roman
palin es ist zeit den zug zu verlassen
hier in angenehmen gebirgs klima hatten
die kolonialherren ihre sommerresidenzen
wir nehmen die pferdekutsche lief früher
g2 ist eine lokale berühmtheit
seit vielen jahren schreibt er bücher
über die politik burmas und das
vermächtnis der britischen kolonialmacht
alles gut
kutschen wie diese benutzten schon die
briten vor 100 jahren der person
uhrenturm ein geschenkter englischen
königin victoria
und auch heute noch habe puma seine
kolonialherren erklärt mir der 82
jährige autor schießen
früher nahmen die briten alle rohstoffe
burmas heute die chinesen
sie nehmen alles einfach alles viel mehr
als die briten chinesen neben mehr
rohstoff was früher die briten ist dass
sein neuer form von kolonialismus
wir sind doch wieder eine kolonie oma
ist doch eine kolonie von china die
spuren der alten kolonialherren sind
heute nur noch touristische attraktionen
der sommerpalast der britischen
gouverneure von burma ist heute ein
hotel
nun also das haus des google news
gleichen andré etwas skurril und
gruselig sam tiguan als wachsfiguren er
zb regional gordon smith wurde 19 46 aus
dem land gejagt zwei jahre später wurde
burma unabhängig also hier gewohnt ja
während des sommers es war ein
rückzugsort fotos zeugen vom feudalen
leben stehen die britischen
kolonialherren nahmen ihre gesamte
dienerschaft aus indien mit ihre
nachfahren leben bis heute in polen und
jede bar whisky war wichtig sie hatten
ein schwimmbad im speisesaal
das war wie die familie des gouverneurs
ja alles für die familie vor allem
reiche russ mieten hier zimmer für 2000
dollar die nacht erzählt mir
mit den engländern kamen auch die
christlichen missionare diese kirche
wurde früher kirche von england genannt
wollte heißt sie allerheiligenkirche
allerheiligenkirche in seinen büchern
zeigt gut schied wie auch das
selbstherrliche gebaren der
kolonialherren
das foto der tiger jagt wurde schon fast
zum tisch für die arroganz der briten
hinterließen die briten auch gut
ja die schulen und spitäler die schule
die european high school war sehr
berühmt es gab es eine mission schulen
und andere christliche einrichtungen die
spitäler waren in einem asiatischen und
europäischen teil aufgeteilt
der europäische bahn und den briefen
vorbehalten
ihre ärzte kamen aus europa
und in anderen teil waren alles asiaten
auch wir lesen hat sie viele regierung
wies die lage der burmesen heute es ist
keine zivile regierung
die militärs haben die uniformen gegen
zivile kleider ausgetauscht bis heute
haben sie eine sperrminorität im
parlament von 25 prozent und die
restlichen 5 17 prozent sind alles ex
militär
gucci zwar hat sich mit seinen
äußerungen noch nie zurückgehalten
auch nicht unter dem militärregime und
obwohl im herbst wahlen stattfinden
braucht er nicht mehr daran dass er
echte demokratie in seinem land erleben
wird man dabei die stadt wurde in vielen
gedichten und liedern besungen
heute ist er seine nüchterne großstadt
deren charme sich einem nicht sofort
erschließt in diesem hotel dürfen
ausschließlich einheimische wohnen hier
treffen wir die katzenfamilie ist ihm
zuwider
sie ist mitten in den vorbereitungen für
die diplomfeier ihrer tochter kein
aufwand ist zu groß
ein visagist schminkt gleich alle drei
töchter heute soll alles perfekt sein
das ist wunderbar so etwas gibt's nur
einmal im leben darum bin ich so
glücklich
die eltern haben ihren weniges erspartes
zusammengelegt um die erfolgreiche
tochter zu feiern
ich habe drei töchter
sie haben alle eine gute ausbildung
ich bin stolz auf meine zwei söhnen
dagegen haben nicht einmal die
highschool geschafft die eltern wissen
dass der weg aus der armut nur über eine
gute ausbildung führt darum ist der
heutige tag eine große genugtuung für
sie es ist ein wichtiger tag für meine
tochter und für mich wir sind nicht
reich trotzdem gehen wir den kindern
eine gute ausbildung
die eltern sind zum ersten mal in
mandala zur großen freude der tochter
haben sie den weiten weg auf sich
genommen
meine eltern sind beide nicht gebildet
als meine schwester ihre abschlussfeier
hatte war ich dabei meine eltern nicht
um eine feier wollten sie nun aber
unbedingt teilnehmen
ich wollte ihnen diesen wunsch natürlich
erfüllen und habe die einladung für sie
organisiert als nächstes geht's zum
fotografen
fast so wichtig wie die feier sind die
fotos vorher auch alle verwandten werden
diese fotos bekommen und sie aufhängen
ich kenne dieses ritual aus china die
wichtigen stationen im leben wie geburt
diplomfeier und hochzeit werden von
einem profi fotografen in szene gesetzt
[Musik]
das käme etwas höher
die den kopf gerade halten lächeln
auf dem universitätsgelände treffen die
studenten nach und nach mit ihren
familien ein
hunderte werden heute ihren bachelor
abschluss erhalten
jetzt wo sich das land geöffnet hat ist
die hoffnung der jungen absolventen aber
ein besseres leben kurs wir dürfen mit
der kamera nur aufs gelände aber nicht
mit so feier aus angst vor unerwünschter
berichterstattung wird mir in meinem
team der zugang verwehrt
kürzlich gab es hier zu
studentenprotesten
nach einer stunde ist die feier vorbei
gespannt erwarte ich mal luca
diese beiden frauen sind angehörige der
paarung in der haid burmas ein monster
minderheiten hier kommen viele zusammen
gerade nation darf ich das diplom sehen
ein großer tag schüssel
jetzt wo ich das diplom habe werde ich
mir einen guten job suchen und mehr geld
verdienen als bisher
ich bin sehr glücklich mandala früher
könig statt wo einst der palast könig
timo stand heißt heute das militär
der letzte könig burmas wurde 18 85 von
den briten nach indien ins exil
geschickt eine große demütigung für
viele burmesen von den 55 millionen
einwohner burmas 10 fast 90 prozent
buddhisten
ich besuche die man harmonie bruder
pagode eine der berühmtesten im land
[Musik]
die gläubigen bekleben buddha figuren
mit hauchdünnen goldfolie eine sakrale
handlung die nur männer ausführen dürfen
über die jahre wird die wertvolle
schicht immer dicker mit einer kleinen
investition soll hier aus schlechtem
karma gutes karma werden
und das lassen sich selbst ärmere
menschen etwas kosten
allein
ja
ich will wissen wie diese gold folien
hergestellt werden und gehe zur straße
der golfschläger schon zu zeiten und
könig kiro hat es hier so geklungen
denke ich es ist als rhythmische hemmen
der golfschläger eine äußerst
anstrengende arbeit die muskelkraft um
präzision erfordert der beruf gab es
schon vor 5000 jahren die männer
schlagen das gut so lange bis es
hauchdünn ist vom klopfen wird das gold
heiß an der temperatur spüren die männer
ob das gold nun genügend rhön ist um aus
blattgold verwendet zu werden
es ist ein sehr harter job wie schaffen
sie das
es ist das einzige was ich gelernt habe
es sieht aus als ob sie in eine art
trance geraten als er tritt muss ja der
rhythmus ist eingängig
[Musik]
hallo sind sie die geschäftsführerin
darf ich eintreten bwin führt das
familienunternehmen ihre großeltern
haben noch für könig timo gearbeitet sie
ihre angestellten packen die hauchdünnen
goldfolie behutsam ein
jede einzelne gutes karma gibt es ab
umgerechnet knapp 4 franken zu kaufen
mein großvater baute das geschäft auf
dann übergabe es meiner mutter die mit
80 jahren verstorben ist
das geschäft ist über ein oder gerig
[Musik]
ich bin nun 51 und ich habe immer hier
gearbeitet mein ganzes leben
[Musik]
die mönche im kloster machern der ion
sind schon seit 4 uhr auf 1200 mönche
und novizen leben hier
das kloster liegt in an era pur einem
vorort von vanderlande jede burmesische
familie gibt ihre söhne für eine gewisse
zeit ins kloster buddhistische mönche
sind in burma ein wichtiger teil des
politischen lebens in diesem kloster
wird viel über die verbindung von
buddhismus und demokratie nachgedacht
achim keller sa hat darüber ein buch
geschrieben
er reist auch schon mal in den westen
und die menschen in buddhistischer
lebensführung und meditation zu
unterrichten
wie jeden tag macht er sich bereit für
den garten ins dorf
[Musik]
auch er ist lehrer wie alle münchner in
diesem kloster
die glaubensbrüder unterrichten in ihrer
freizeit die kinder aus dem dorf zum
beispiel in englischer sprache
[Musik]
afrika sammelt die spenden der gläubigen
ein
viele der bewohner bereiten speisen wie
die mönche zu gute taten erzeugen ein
gutes karma und was schlägt sich positiv
auf eine auffällige wiedergeburt nieder
glauben die buddhisten
[Musik]
beim burmesischen vollkommen man hier
ein hohes ansehen
häufig sind hier ist die intervenieren
wenn das regime zu rücksichtslos mit den
menschen umgeht
[Musik]
das war auch so als 2007 wenn ich auf
die straße gingen um gegen das
militärische zu protestieren tausende
von zivilisten schlossen sich ihnen an
mönche haben zwar kein stimmrecht aber
die übergangsregierung weiß dass sie es
sich nicht leisten kann
die glaubensbrüder zu ignorieren
allerdings so friedlich und aufgeklärt
wie achim keller sei sie nicht alle
menschen in burma immer wieder hätten
radikale nationalistische glaubensbrüder
gegen die muslimische minderheit im land
es kommt zur brutalen übergriffen achim
keller verurteilt das schärfste
ich würde mich mit dem willen
friedfertig zu sein und auch danach zu
leben das ist der sinn sondern ein
buddhistischer mönch ist buddhismus
heißt auch alle negativen gefühle in
sich selbst auszulöschen
wenn ich wütend auf dich bin bin ich für
meine wut selbst verantwortlich das hat
mit dir nichts zu tun
wie kann man also als manch gewalttätig
sein mich ist das unmöglich ich schäme
mich und werde das nie befürworten wenn
ich zu so was genötigt wurde durch
heimgehen
mein vater würde sie freuen wo steht das
land in zehn jahren
das land wird sich sowieso von grund auf
ändern
fundamentale änderungen stehen bevor das
weiß auch die regierung die generäle
nicht bloß ihre uniformen ab hat sich
wirklich
ich bin überzeugt dass sie heute ihre
grenzen kennen und sie wissen dass sie
sich mit
folge und der internationalen
gemeinschaft verständigen heute haben
sie ein gutes einvernehmen mit dem
westen und den usa das wollen sie nicht
aufs spiel setzen langsam fangen sie an
zu verstehen
vorher hatten sie keine bildung in
meinem buch erkläre ich dass demokratie
ohne bildung nie erfolgreich sein kann
aber bildung beginnt nicht erst an der
universität sondern schon im
kindergarten
ich sage immer es braucht fast 20 jahre
eine generation und dann noch einmal 20
jahre bis die demokratie wirklich
funktioniert der weg ist noch lang aber
der erste schritt ist gemacht
der weg ist noch sehr lang aber es gibt
keine alternative
mit den anbietern offen und ehrlich sein
ich muss mich auch zum tatgeschehen das
name war
wenn du so michaela verbessern weil man
negative gedanken aber verbuchten aber
210 mit ihr los
zuerst aber es mache aber dann loslassen
und das sind sachen die höchste aber
eben nur das geschärfte bewusstlos als
wirklich so ganz viele andere mit mir
ans herz
während
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge überlasse ich mich
der magie von pagani der mystischen
jahrtausendealten verboten fällt aber in
lassie treffe ich allein fischer und
muss erfahren wieso diese idylle bald
ein ende haben könnte und die burmesen
lieben kickboxen mit einem champion
steige ich in den ring
[Musik]
rot grün rot mit globetrotter und
fernsehfestival siebte bis achte
november im kursaal bern fernsehfestival
punkt ch